hi I'm Priscilla Chan and I'm Sal Khan
and we're here to announce the
breakthrough junior challenge for those
of you who don't know the breakthrough
prize is a is a prize to the world's top
mathematicians and scientists for
discoveries that are going to change the
world around us and the breakthrough
junior challenge is to reach out to high
school students with a recognition that
the biggest breakthroughs start with an
insight with a new way of looking at
things
it could be existing discoveries or
theories it could be a recent one or it
could be something that you you discover
on your own we want to hear from you all
you scientists tinker's innovators in
the world
send us your video we want to hear from
you by October 7th in a short video
where you explain what you're excited
about these days and what do they win
this is this is pretty exciting as in
itself you'll win a college scholarship
your teacher will get a prize for being
such an important mentor in your life
and your school gets a brand-new lab for
everyone to be able to work hands-on and
learn about science and they get to fly
out here oh yeah this is the most
glamorous science event in the world
best science fair ever and we can't wait
to see what you produce
we suspect that you're going to blow our
minds and open many many more people's
minds to to the magic of science that
will eventually lead to future
breakthroughs we're so excited we can't
wait to hear from you